hello out there folks
it's Sunday yeah it's another little
update pandemic update we told you we'd
walk you through it yeah you know a lot
of crazy stories out today be careful
you know be careful what you listen to
and notice that all the stories all the
news stories contradict each other
and you can plainly see who's spinning
the pro CCP narrative about a lot of
Chinese Communist Party propaganda out
there it's just obvious I mean you know
they bought their way into the United
States and they're just you know China
didn't do it you know it's just whatever
you know what I mean then they say
United States did it they're saying that
it's crazy everybody know everybody
knows where Wuhan is that's why I don't
want it yeah just be careful what you
believe it's obvious you can obviously
you can see who where the CCP money is
being spent but we had requests right
yeah like I said it's Sunday we actually
recorded the Tuesday's show last night
so I'm still pretty like tired and [ __ ]
yeah
but you know that I'll go up on Tuesday
except for the patrons who will see it
on Monday yeah so hopefully you guys
like that it ended up being 3 hours and
17 minutes long there's a long show it
was good show it was very long so we
didn't finish until really really late
but yes so think about pancakes we did
make pancakes at like midnight or so
[Laughter]
yeah we did have we had another request
to do because a lot of people have
reached out to me and said they really
liked me doing a book recommendation
some people also said they would like
some music recommendations so maybe you
can come up with some of those I come
I'm calling so um I actually got an idea
because I was gonna do some more book
recommendations anyway but then while we
were doing the show last night and when
you listen to it on Tuesday you'll see I
kind of I don't even remember how I went
off on this tangent but we're talking
about like adaptations of Edgar Allan
Poe stories and I was like oh I should
talk about that a little bit on the show
even though I did you know what it's
like I was looking there's a Wikipedia
page
of films that are adapted from Edgar
Allan Poe stories and there was a bunch
in there that I didn't even know we're
supposed to be adaptations of Edgar
Allan Poe stories like there's one it's
pretty recent I think it came out in
2014 and it's like I keep seeing it like
every time I scroll through the horror
movies on Netflix and it's called
stonehearst asylum and I didn't realize
but that is actually supposed to be
based on kind of a lesser-known Poe
story called the system of dr. Tarr and
professor fether
so it's like oh well [ __ ] I might watch
it now and I think we talked about
extraordinary tales too which is either
on shudder and Netflix which is like a
animated anthology which is actually
pretty good like I said the Roger Corman
ones are easily my favorite the ones
with Vincent Price in them and also the
premature burial with Ray Milland which
is also really good I dug that one a lot
and there's a couple giallo ones too
there was and I didn't actually realize
this but there's kind of a well known GL
and would be called your vice is a
locked room and only I have the key and
that is actually based on the black cat
and also Lucci Oh fold she did a
adaptation of the black cat and Dario
Argento did an adaptation of the black
cat in two evil eyes which I think also
had an adaptation of the facts in the
case of M Valdemar which I think George
Romero directed I remember liking that
movie it's pretty cheesy because I think
it came out in the 80s but it's you know
it's it's pretty gory and crazy and [ __ ]
like that
and since we're talking about Edgar
Allan Poe I wanted to show you guys this
I've got this like a long time ago and
I'm sorry if you just listen to the
audio cuz you can't see it but there's
this really it's kind of like a
biography sort of of Edgar Allen Poe and
it's kind of like goes through all his
stories and everything like that and
check this [ __ ] out it's like when you
open it up I don't know how much it
costs to produce this book because it's
amazing but you go in here and it's like
it's all Illustrated like this you know
what I mean and then like sometimes look
at this you guys there's like there's
like these little like paper envelopes
in here and they have like letters and
like reproductions of like letters and
newspapers and stuff like that like from
Edgar Allan Poe
dan you can take them out and like
unfold them and stuff it's really cool
it's like a Nick Van toc type of thing
which I have all his books too but yeah
that's like really cool if you can find
it um you can probably see that better
cuz that kind of has all the stuff
that's like fold it out you know what I
mean
but yeah it's super read and I got it it
[ __ ] Barnes & Noble for like eight
bucks or something like that
holy crap yeah yeah so I got a couple
recommendations if you like fiction you
like kind of ghost story type stuff I
just read this one really recently
someone recommended it to me and it's
really good it's called a head full of
ghosts by Paul Tremblay and it's kind of
about a girl who possibly schizophrenic
possibly possessed by a demon and it's
kind of told by her sister like in
flashback and there was also like a
paranormal reality show that was going
on about her like they were making a
paranormal reality show about her so
it's kind of like a narrative of like a
reality show narrative and you're not
really sure like whether she was really
like schizophrenic or there was a demon
or whatever also here's one that's kind
of a book and a music recommendation
there's actually a whole series of these
I have this one I think I might have the
smiths one too but it's called perverted
by language and it's short stories that
are inspired by the songs of the fall
who I am actually a really big fan of a
Marky Smith died not too long ago which
it's weird you didn't hear much about it
but I guess the fall are like hardly
known in this country even though they
had a song in Silence of the Lamb so you
can't really hear it but um yeah this is
like really cool it's very it's not
horror really it's more like weird indie
experimental type of stuff like I said I
think I have the Smiths one someplace
too but I couldn't find it there's
there's another Smith's one and I think
there's I can't remember what all bands
there are there might be a Joy Division
one there might be but there's like a
whole series of these and they're pretty
cool that's why I've actually want to
get those now this one is nonfiction and
I thought this was kind of a good thing
to read if everyone's like cuz
everyone's freaking out about the
pandemic this is a classic this is the
culture of fear why Americans are afraid
of the wrong things
lassiter it's like it came out several
years ago but it's really really good
because it's kind of going into some of
the stuff's out of date now because it's
talking about how you know they're
talking about like how Bruce freaking
out about like the crack epidemic and
the white okay all this I think this
might have been before that or I don't
know if he talked about that but um yeah
he talks about all different kind of
stuff in there he talks about plane
crashes in there which actually made me
feel a lot better about flying even
though I still hate it it's just
basically talking about how you know
statistically people you know people are
afraid of things that statistically are
very rare like terrorism and stuff like
that instead of being afraid of like car
crashes or something like that which is
much more likely to happen to you so
it's actually a really good read I've
read it several times and I would
recommend it for anybody to get stressed
out about watching the news or whatever
because it's it's a good dose of reality
I mean do you have any music
recommendations yeah I got one um well I
got a couple of them yeah if you guys
have never heard Sisters of Mercy man
you got to you got to go on YouTube and
look look for the Sisters of Mercy and
go and listen to that first last and
always album the quintessential gothic
rock out me yeah I showed that dissent
to some young guy man on Facebook you
know whose listens to the show and he's
just like freaked out over these fine
fine merch and everything yes gosh you
know shirts he's like man that's a
really good album it's mostly just that
album they had other good albums after
that they weren't quite the same because
the band changed out they went a little
metal yeah or not there's anything wrong
with that but it's kind of lost that
particulars more glam rock a little bit
yeah but the first and the what's called
first last and always yeah first and
last and always yeah things what's
called yeah and that's a classic album
another one you know everybody likes pop
music and there's this band that I like
called death in Rome yeah and it's
mostly an online ban they make videos
and put them up online and they got
their own channel on YouTube death in
Rome and what it is is it's they'll take
famous pop songs they do them
in the same kind of neo folk style as
death in June so there it's awesome yeah
it's kind of like you know the German
Germanic neo-paganism you know
interpretation of say like you know like
in Madonna songs just any any kind of
hit they've done it yeah you know they
do a lot of 80s a lot of 80s early 90s
because probably one of my favorites
about the jam they did pump up the jam
yeah they did probably my favorite ones
are take on me the AHA and love is a
battlefield
yeah the Pat Benatar one it's just
really funny to me how a song like that
which I like those songs in their
original forms any way I could into
eighties music but it's funny how you
can take something like that and turn it
into like like this uber gothy like you
know drenched an atmosphere kind of
thing and it totally works yeah it's
like if you didn't know it was a cover
you wouldn't know yeah it's kind of like
you know dark vocals and real slowed
down and and mostly acoustic with you
know big timpani and stuff boom boom
yeah you know trying to do almost kind
of like an operatic or the Cowles kind
of like weird opera mixed with folk you
just got to see it for yourself go up
first one I recommend would probably be
like pump up the jams but yeah bye-bye
dead by death in Rome yeah you'll like
that one and also the the take on me
yeah that was a good one like I said
love is a battlefield love is a
battlefield I call me my favorite
they're all good they're good I have a
bunch of him on my phone like what you
know walk and stuff like that a camera
what's that one they did that was a
wasn't was it Barbie girl yeah did they
do a version of Barbie girl died Sun by
aqua yep and I did that one they did
they did a bunch of them they did a [ __ ]
now I can't do anything was improbable
anything that's improbable they'll do it
yeah and like I said it's a lot of 80s
I'm like early nineties stuff yeah um
but yeah they're really good I like them
a lot I was one band I want to recommend
I don't actually I don't even know if
they're still around I bought some of
their albums like back in the mid to
late 2000s maybe um and if you really
like kind of old-school like gothic rock
or death rockers
thing like that but with a weird like
creepy you know Joy Division closer kind
of vibe they're called submarine fleet I
have one full-length album and like one
like a EP and they're really really good
I mean you wouldn't know cuz I've had
them on in the car I think one time and
you thought they were like an old band
yeah but but they're not they're fairly
recent right and they have like some
kind of like more up be like poppy songs
and stuff like that but then a lot of
their stuff like the one album of theirs
that I have which i think is called a
very strange site in the distance and
it's really like this creepy I mean
they're they're really like aptly named
you know what I mean because they sound
like this weird like underwater like
distant kind of like kind of sound and
it's like really really cool we said
what was another death and rum song that
they did where they did it they cut up a
demo a Czechoslovakian movie where the
guy was killing the dude in the dam damn
it see now it's like an answer really
but it's a really good song it's a cover
but it yeah it was really good it's one
of their best songs yeah I think that's
pretty much all they do is cover yes
everything's covers but yeah as what I'm
what I'm like more prepared I'll come
out with like some more music stuff and
like more books and stuff because I have
like millions of see guys ii I've had
guys asked me if they should still be
going to work or if they should just
hide out man go to work well if you need
money then yeah kind of have to go to
work right just take precautions try to
get some masks and some gloves and you
know to get real close to people and
we'll keep washing your hands try not to
touch your face make people don't stop
chances are you're not I mean if you're
if you're in a if you're in a real
populated area like a city you've
already got it probably yeah and chances
are you won't even know that you have it
yes most people who catch it don't don't
really get that sick I've been talking
to people I think I already had it you
don't believe it but there of people I
said it's possible rather than like it
was just like a long time like a lot of
people I've talked to it around that
same time they have the same symptoms
where you get sick for a few hours then
it goes away and you get sick and it was
just real mild a real wild I've had
colds and fleas like that yeah like a
real mild flu and it seemed like I've
been talking to people and is around
that
same time and annoy it lasts about 10
days yeah you know I think I already had
it
well no talent that's what I mean and
unless they had tested you at the time
you would never know because like I said
there's other strains of flu going
around to look just like there are every
year so at this point there would be no
way of knowing yeah and if you know the
guy who asked is actually like in I
think he said he was in New Mexico or
Arizona and he's in a desert area where
it's hot yeah hot and dry and not
densely populated men go to work yeah
well maybe if you need to if you need to
you know I mean but you know keep going
to work just take putt just take kind of
you know precautions if you can get a
good mask get it and some goggles you
know just kind of steer clear people
wear gloves so you know if you get the
infection that's on the gloves you can
take gloves off but just make sure you
keep washing yourself you know your
hands on your face and with you know
alcohol or just even soap any any way
you know anything is better than nothing
but you know if everybody stops working
at the exact same time including those
truck drivers that's a wrap
well now if the truck driver stops a rat
all [ __ ] yeah civilization will fall
apart in a few days okay we've got we
need the truck driver get if they need
the truck drivers and the nurses and the
doctors and shellay yeah if they quit
going to work and within three days it
would be Mad Max because the cities will
starve they don't you know food is
direct is delivered instantly and if a
city you know Katrina will teach you
that if a city loses nine misses nine
meals that's it and a few days later man
cannibalism starts to become a damn
possibility infant in when Stalingrad
got surrounded or got cut off because it
because the Germans were fighting over
in World War two there was cannibalism
going on in there
yeah well people get hung sort of
desperate means yeah but you know a lot
of it some of them will start will flip
over quick because they you know they
want to flip to cannibalism while
they're still strong yeah that way they
can overpower people yeah that depends
on the situation I think that's a very
very extreme chances are it would
be an explosion of murder like Katrina
but who knows maybe there was
cannibalism going on in Katrina there's
no like I said I guess there's no way
and there's no way to know there they
never found never found a lot of people
yeah so money but yeah and it was but
that was before cell phones and stuff
were real common with the head you know
I don't even think YouTube existed I
remember the other day I was like
looking up and somebody had mentioned
like when YouTube started like when the
first video what and it was much later
than I yeah they had remembered they had
cell phones but they weren't as good as
now you could they couldn't really
access the web and they really didn't
have you know you really couldn't get
video on him real well yeah they were
shitty there was shitty but you know if
that it happened in modern times we'd
know more about what happened in Katrina
but no work for you know if your job
exists keep going to it just take
precautions yeah like I said cuz a lot
of people they told them not to come to
work and now they're kind of hosed
because it's like you know they don't
know if they're gonna get paid or not so
right now we'll see how so like I said
if you can afford to stay home then stay
home but to be totally honest with you
most you people that were sent home
because your jobs you know job closed
down I think at least half of them jobs
will probably never reopen they might
not because what that does to a business
it might be irrecoverable yeah it might
be cheaper whoever owns that business to
change the business model completely so
I would they're trying to hook up
something where they're paying people to
stay at home it's like unemployment well
like I said they're gonna have to do
something like that because otherwise
people need money to live and you need
money to keep the economy going and if
nobody has any money to buy anything the
economy crumble yeah I just I I read an
article again the other day because like
I said I read a lot of food blogs and
stuff like that and I'm kind of
interested in how this is affecting the
you know restaurant and food industry
because you know obviously a lot of
restaurants had to close and they said
what a lot of restaurants did I mean
other than going to just delivery only
some of them are now acting like grocery
stores because they had like a bunch of
food still so those are so and they're
just like hey you want like you know
eight dozen eggs or something like that
so they're just
selling them off to the public so the
public can come and pick them up which
you know I think that's a good and they
have secured two lines of supply yeah
like for instance you might go to go
down to boil trap a call right now and
get a bunch of cooked chickens yeah they
might have a special deal here's a bag
of four cooked chickens so you know it's
like I don't know how I you know I don't
know how widespread it is but there are
like a significant number of restaurants
that are doing that yeah you know just
because they're not serving anybody in
house anymore and they have like all
this food and they're afraid it'll go
bad so to have everything divided up
they have everything divided up and
they're they're ready to cut those damn
roads off because when the six start
showing up in the hospital they'll know
where all the sick people are I just saw
somebody I I think it was our friend
will I think he posted a picture of
downtown Orlando like last night
sometime and there was like nobody's
like one car
yeah like out there record yeah they
don't know where the sick people are
there's a curfew at least in Orlando I
don't know about Olive Florida but
there's a curfew from 11:00 p.m. to 5:00
a.m. you're allowed to still be around
to be out if you have to go to work and
[ __ ] like that obviously or you know if
you have an emergency but other than
that I don't know if they'll arrest you
or just find you or I don't know what
they'll do
they're doing the right thing they're
assuming that densely populated cities
that depend upon mass transit like
subways
they're probably heavily affected yeah
so that means in New York well like I
said there's no way to avoid it because
we have light of people touching things
on I mean flus are really parts parts of
California really contagious at the best
of times and you know yeah I don't
really think it's will be too bad in our
area probably not no public
transportation to speak of not really
there's buses but you know not enough
it's not very common let's take them
most people have their own cars yeah and
where we live like I said it's kind of
we don't live in the middle of Orlando
we live like about 19 18 miles outside
of downtown Orlando like in kind of a
suburban area so yeah you know it'll be
alright I would think that you know it's
damn near pandemonium happening in Italy
and I think Italy is two weeks ahead of
us yeah so we'll know in a couple weeks
yeah we'll see how it happens I think
they met what some people are saying
that hey there was why didn't they
respond earlier this is an early
response this is way early yeah this is
where
early because you don't have thousands
of sick people swapping that in the
hospitals yet that's a couple more
couple ease away from that yeah like so
now it is so I think I hopefully we
caught it in time
yeah contain the spreads just a few
areas yep so yeah everybody just trace
try to stay positive yep they're chill
out like I said it's it sucks but
there's really not much you can do other
than try to keep yourself safe and just
watch things unfold and yeah just try to
keep your [ __ ] together if they sent
your ass home keep an eye on that job
see if that job evaporates yeah I would
just plan for an online future if you
can yeah that's what its gonna go to
probably yeah so uh have a happy rest of
your Sunday yeah and we'll be talking to
you again next week's like yeah thanks
for like ending on a bum note yeah just
trying to keep [ __ ] realist I just you
know I was like hey we'll talk about
some loose and music and stuff and then
Tom comes and yeah all doom and gloom
once again well don't want to overreact
but you also don't want to [ __ ] pump
people full of [ __ ] you know I mean
sunshine yeah but I I think at this
point most people know that it's a
shitty situation and I think people are
just trying to like they're like hey I
know it's bad I know I'd you know I'm
stuck in my house so it's like I just
want like some fun [ __ ] I don't believe
this is a civilization ending event no I
don't think it's just a temporary
setback and it's gonna accelerate the
way it was going that's gonna accelerate
it forward like five years in just a few
months yeah that's gonna happen which
like I said in the long run that might
work out or not okay yeah they might
work out better just I'm trying to try
to see a silver I think remain gum be
flexible yeah I'll be pokey yeah all
right we'll talk to you again next time
we talk to you which will probably be
tomorrow